you know what you never know when a good  90 song is going to come on and like its  salt and peppers what a man just like  then like I got a running man you don't  know I can't be like held back because  of the clothes Nicole Richie nose at  Iraq that comfy chic look at last night  she launched her house of harlow 1960  collaboration with online retailer raval  and Cameron Diaz came out in her summer  white to support her fashionista  sister-in-law where did the inspiration  come from um well my kids always inspire  me and I really wanted to celebrate la  ok so I have to ask you because Father's  Day is coming up what do you do so this  Father's Day my dad's not here and  Joel's not here so what we're gonna do  is we're gonna celebrate it later on and  we'll probably do it in in July and  we'll probably just do it one big family  just get everybody together